[Music]
Well, welcome to another edition of AP's
Profiles in Christian Living. My name is
Mark Powell and I'm the convenor for the
National Journal of the Presbyterian
Church of Australia called AP. My
special guest with me today is, I think,
one of my academic heroes, Dr. Raben
Ibrahim. Dr. Ibrahim is the author of
numerous books particularly on the topic
of Islamic military conflict with
Christianity. He's also significantly uh
fluent in Arabic and English which gives
him I think a particularly unique
ability to engage in this particular
subject. Dr. Ibrahim, welcome. It really
is a great honor to be able to interview
you interview you and and learn from
you.
>> Uh thanks very much Mark. I'm happy to
uh be with you and uh you know to to
reach out to all the people down under
because I hear from them often and I'm
happy to do um an interview with one of
their own platforms.
>> Yeah, look it's fantastic. Um it really
is I think your books uh I've only
really I think been introduced to them
in the last couple of years. Uh but if I
could start by asking you um a personal
question uh I ask all my guests this
question at the start uh and that is you
were raised by Coptic parents. Um could
you explain what faith in Jesus means
for you personally?
>> Yeah, I was uh born and raised and
baptized in the Coptic Orthodox Church.
You know, the most summary way I can
tell you is I am Orthodox in outlook. Um
that however having said that it's hard
not to be Protestantized despite oneself
being born and raised in America or in a
western nation in general. In fact, uh
it may amuse you to learn that my one of
my siblings is a um flaming Calvinist
and he'll defend it to the end. Um but
um you know I'm ultimately really my um
theological outlook is very much of a uh
it's kind of like a mere Christianity of
the CS Lewis variety. Okay, where it's,
you know, it's very broad and general
and it's based on a very few principles
um including the growing and applicable
slogan that Christ is king. Okay. Um but
other than that, I'm not uh it's hard
for me to kind of uh really articulate.
I'm not I'm not an emotional Christian.
I'm not a sentimental Christian. Uh I'm
more of a civilizational one, I think.
And I think that comes out in my work,
as we'll be seeing. In other words, for
me, Christendom is much more important
as a as a sort of cultural and social
outgrowth and as a kingdom that's
developing and progressing rather than,
you know, um it's a sentimental kind of
feeling that I have that's internalized.
In fact, I sort of have a problem with
that kind of Christianity. I think that
that's that's what takes away from the
other kind and sort of weakens society
when it becomes overly individualized.
Um so yeah that's you know the bare bone
background for my faith. you know, you
you say that and uh I want to get into
this a little bit with you as well
because um you I think model for me uh
not just uh physically but also I think
intellectually a muscular kind of
Christianity u in that I I as I read
your books I I think it's dominated by
an outspokenenness, a courage
particularly in responding to Islam and
and I find this a lot with like uh
Christians that have come from Egyp
Egypt uh where they've seen the threat
of Islam. How much do you think your
personal background influences you um
when you when you come to this topic?
>> Yeah, I mean it it definitely does. Um
on the one hand, I'm born and raised in
the United States, but on the other
hand, I grew up my family, like I said,
cops from Egypt. So just from day one,
I'm I'm I'm exposed to the Arabic
language. I'm hearing about the past.
I'm familiar with stories. So obviously
unlike your average American, I have
that sort of connection um with the
Islamic world and Christianity and how
it fits in. On the other hand, I suppose
my American side and mostly my historic
side uh you know gravitates towards how
Christians actually responded when they
were not them forced to be secondass
citizens and that would be you know the
par excellence example would be the
crusaders for example. So, um, when I
look at those types of Christians, the
you mentioned muscular Christianity, you
know, that's them right there. They're
the paragonss. Um, so I think that also
motivates me. I'm very much uh a
historical creature. I know much more
about history than oftentimes, and kind
of embarrassing to say, what's happening
today. Um, and I think that has to do
with my outlook. I have a sort of, if
you're familiar with the hedgehog versus
Fox mentality, mine's the former where I
just have, you know, one main idea and
everything can fit into it. I don't have
to know the news because I know how
things work. Um, thanks to my knowledge
and and, you know, closeness with
history. Um but yeah that's uh so that's
really a little bit of my background is
sort of yes I always say personally and
privately my own ethnic upbringing but
also my own sort of proclivities for
history and for how Christianity used to
be all of these merge together and make
me the vocal person you see.
>> Yeah that's a fascinating insight you're
talking about right now. My um my son um
is a budding historian himself and uh
and he often says to me how important
the study of history is and yet the
younger generation coming up is
basically historically illiterate. Um
what fascinates me about all of your
writings is it's just saturated in
history. Um can you explain, you know,
just go into that a little bit more
detail? Um the the fox and the hedgehog
analogy. Why is the study of history so
important for being able to understand
world events today?
>> Yeah, I actually, you know, a long time
ago, I I concluded that the secret to
everything, whether it's uh even
including theology, is found in history.
And um and the problem is, you know, you
you mentioned correctly that people are
dumb down historically. But I believe
that's by design because if people don't
know where they come from, what the
roots are, what led to where we got,
then that's been it's and the sad part
is it hasn't just been forgotten, it's
been rewritten to be the exact opposite
often times. Um, which leads to all the
lunacy we're dealing with. Um, but as as
for the fox and the hedgehog, you know,
that goes back to one of Asop's fables,
which has its own specific meaning, but
I think um Isaiah Berlin, a philosopher,
wrote a little essay about it. And you
know the long and short of it is that
the hedgehog knows one big thing. The
fox knows a lot of little things. Okay.
And so the question is who is who really
is more knowledgeable? And of course one
would think that the fox is right. But
in fact the hedgehog is because he knows
yet he knows one profound philosophical
truism. And you can think of it as a
paradigm. And therefore whether he knows
all the snippets of facts and news that
develop on a daily basis, it's sort of
irrelevant because they he already knows
how everything fits in and it makes
sense. That's kind of how I approach uh
things and a lot of it is informed by my
knowledge of history and that's why I
was saying news and and the news and the
events that you know I don't really
follow too much because and when I hear
them it's almost like yeah of course it
fits perfect and I understand it. I you
know whereas the Fox and I've often
wondered is was that an inside joke? Is
that why Fox News is called Fox? Um, but
the Fox sounds good because he has a lot
of disparate little pieces of
information that he will gather and he
oh, I'm following the news every day and
I've I've but he never really
synthesizes it and gets a meaningful
hole out of it. Okay? And it's just and
you see this in the nature and the cycle
of the news, right? Monday it's b we're
all talking about this and the left is
angry about this and the right is angry
about that and then tomorrow we press
reset and we start a whole new thing and
nothing's ever really learned. Okay. So,
for instance, I did a re recent video
and article about um if you if you if
you recall um a few maybe a month ago or
two months ago in Syria,
the Drews, a religious minority, were
literally being slaughtered and
massacred. Very horrific things were
happening to them. And the people doing
it were essentially the new the new
leadership of Syria, which used to be
al-Qaeda. Okay. the the man who's right
now their president I think or prime
minister I don't know what he calls
himself I guess president um Ahmed al-
Shar I believe uh well he was al-Qaeda
and the what I wanted to point out is
and and people are again talking like
wow how could this be and it's it's to
me it's become a joke because you go
back to the 80s and every single time US
leadership and the west in general is
always always supportive of Islamic
jihadist terrorists okay whether it was
Reagan with the mujahedi in Afghanistan
or you know fast forward all the way to
ISIS you know before they became ISIS
were freedom fighters around 2010 112 in
Syria and um it's just it's become a
joke so if you follow the news every
every few years a new terrorist group
comes and we all get and then you find
out the west and the US is supporting it
and they're going to be good guys
because they put on a suit and then they
start murdering and slaughtering
Christians and Jews etc etc and everyone
puts hashtags and wow what does this
mean and and we forget because the news
cycle changed and now it's time to talk
about something else and hashtag
something else and uh so my point is
this that's the fox mentality where you
know it just keeps popping up popping up
and you never learn and you never
because you never synthesize them
together in a coherent hole whereas the
hedgehog mentality doesn't even need to
know about all these developments as
they happen because he knows certain
truisms and they always fit in together
and it gives him a comprehensive whole
understanding and going back to history.
I think that's what really complements
the sort of hedgehog mentality is is if
you understand how the truth and the
reality about history, which is, like I
said, I wish people were just ignorant.
They're not. They're actually
intentionally force-fed a fake, often
antithetical history because history
creates narratives and and those who are
feeding us the fake history are trying
to reach a specific narrative.
>> Wow. This is a fascinating insight.
you've got a great um YouTube channel
that's really sort of exploding in
numbers. I I I can I just say I reckon
this would be a really great topic for a
future YouTube the the the fox and the
hedgehog because I think what what you
are modeling and what you're getting to
the heart of is something so important
and um can I just can I just piggyback
on that? um you know after 9/11 uh in
the states uh people were saying well
this is not Islam you know this is um a
bastardized version of Islam that we're
seeing um I I know that you have been
very influential uh in advising um
government what what's your take on 911
is is this and how does that relate to
uh Islam as a religion
Well, 911 and all Islamic terror attacks
how they relate to and yeah, you're
going back to the whole big question
which is is this real Islam? Because
after 911, George W. Bush told us that
uh you know, Islam is a religion of
peace and then the narrative was that
al-Qaeda was hijacking Islam and ISIS is
hijacking Islam and everyone's hijacking
Islam. And on the surface that seems
somewhat logical because they are a
small minority group these terrorist
organizations compared to the Islamic
world at large which is why um you know
it was again going back to history. This
is one of the reasons I wanted to delve
into and write my my first main
historical book, Sword and Scimitar. And
the subtitle will give you an idea of 14
centuries of war between Islam and the
West because I wanted to see so the
ideas that uh you know of Islamic
terrorism attacking infidels and and
terrorizing them essentially is that an
aberration that you know al-Qaeda and
others have pioneered or what? And well,
lo and behold, you find out no, that was
the modus operandi of all Islamic groups
going back to the highest leaders and
levels, which is the caliphates and the
sultanates. That's precisely how they
fought and how they acted. Um, which is
to basically if you're a non-Muslim, if
you're an infidel, you are a de facto
enemy. You and if we can rec if Muslims
are able to, they're strong. Um, you
know, then they can attack and you have
three choices. Convert, become
secondass, demi, or fight to the death,
etc. that was the general history of
Islam. The visa v everyone. Um so I
think that's that was the uh that's what
the best way to understand it. But you
know Islam is not stupid and it's very
it's supposed to work. In other words, a
khalif or a sultan should not
willy-nilly declare jihad. It should
also always be done when he has a good
chance u of success. Okay. Um so in a
way the Islamic terror groups are
somewhat of an aberration because they
just u you know they just create terror
and attack and you know oftentimes it's
interesting because if you talk to
anyone in the Islamic world and and the
non-west ISIS is a creation of the west.
I mean they're almost all convinced of
it. Um and there are interesting you
know conver there there are interesting
insights of that. I already pointed out
how the west is always on the side of
Islamic terrorists that never changes.
So on the one hand I think it's obvious
that they at least use them um the west
uses the Islamic terror groups for its
own agenda but it might be even darker
than that because um if you really look
at some of the things you know think
about it when ISIS as it does very
recently and and they do this all the
time they their main message to Western
Muslims is go out and kill infidels kill
and drive your truck into them enter a
church open fire and kill
Okay, on the one hand, this, you know, I
get it. Muslims are angry. They hate the
West for an endless list of reasons as
they see it. Um, but what is to be
gained by that? All right. Uh, when you
do that, and they do that, okay, you've
killed one or two infidels or three, but
look at the um the horrible optics
they've created for themselves, for the
Muslim world. It's actually every time
one of these terrorists do what they do,
that actually is very bad for the
Islamic world. And that's why and I and
again I tell you this because this is
the standard view amongst um Muslims in
Russia and lots of Asia that ISIS is
100% bought and owned by Western forces
and elements. Um so and again I I
mentioned that to you because it is
different in a way from the historical
jihad. The historical jihad of course
the animus and and the violence and the
desire to conquer was always there but
it was done in an intelligent way.
Whereas uh when you look at these groups
and what they do um I just you know when
one really stops and thinks about it
it's hard to determine how are they
helping the Muslim world. Okay, if all
you do is just once in a while go out
and kill go stab children in London and
okay we what is that going to
strategically how's that going to help
Muslims isn't that really going to hurt
them actually and turn you know if
anything just turn public opinion
against them. So, it is kind of an
interesting question, one that I've
really been u sort of reconsidering of
late.
>> Yeah. I mean, to go back in history a
little bit. Um, you know, a friend of
mine gave me your book, uh, Sword and
Scimitar, uh, well over a year ago, and
then I immediately read the next book,
uh, Defenders of the West, and I was
fascinated by some of the case studies
that you did, in particular, you know,
the famous Vlad Dracula from the the
House of the Dragon. Um can you explain
to readers just a a quick in a in a
quick summary nutshell um who was Vlad
Dracula and and why he's such an
important case study to remember?
>> Yeah. So um the reason he's important
I'll start with the second one is
because he's another perfect example of
what I've talked about which is the sort
of demonization
um of an otherwise good possibly noble
definitely uh heroic character. Keep in
mind Vlad Dracula, our Dracula, you
know, the vampire that flutters around
at night and sleeps in a coffin by day,
is a hero in Romania. There's a reason
for that. So, uh, basically Vlad was,
uh, you know, long story short, he was
he was born in Wakia, modern day
Romania, and he became, uh, its ruler
out and and there's a lot of, uh, you
know, internal turmoil politics between
the Ottomans and Hungarian Empire next
Hungar Hungarian Kingdom. And anyway, uh
it's it's very hard to keep power at
that time. You know, I think uh in my
book I talk about how you know his
predecessors and successors there's
something like 20 in like 15 years
because they always get overthrown. So
it required a draconian strong hand, not
least when you're dealing with the
Ottomans, the Turks. And so the Turks
way, you know, that the Ottoman war
machine, which is specifically really
what it was, that existed simply to prey
on, conquer, annex and absorb uh the
persons and and um goods of infidel
nations, almost always Christian ones
around it in the Balkans. uh he Wakio
was so weak at the time and in fact
Vlad's father uh Vlad II was um was an
actual essentially a an ally of the
Ottomans because he had no choice really
even though and I discuss it in the book
when he could he would turn on them and
eventually he got himself killed for his
sort of shifting politics but Vlad would
not have Vlad was kidnapped as a child
and actually a hostage so his father
gave Vlad and his brother Radu
uh as hostages in their youth to the
Ottomans to ensure his goodwill. See,
this is what I mean by he's an ally, but
not really. It's a sort of coerced
relationship. And um in his youth, they
were both very much mistreated. His
brother essentially became a catamite is
what we would call, but essentially the
sexual lover of the Ottoman rulers, both
Morad II, the father, and then Muhammad
II or Mahmed II. And that's in the
sources, so I'm not making that up. Um,
and who knows what happened to Vlad, but
he he was a lot tougher and he was often
whipped and beaten and in prison because
he was very recalcitrant and not
obedient uh to to the Ottomans unlike
his brother. Anyway, eventually he
managed to get away and became the ruler
of Wakia. And immediately, you know,
they sent to him, it's an interesting
anecdote, they sent to him um
emissaries, the Ottomans, saying, "Okay,
it's time for tribute." And uh one of
the main tributes was to offer up
children, Christian boys, the strongest
and healthiest to become janiseries,
warrior soldiers for Islam, to become
Muslim and to become jihadists
essentially. So they could eventually be
sent back on their former kin and kill
them and attack them. Um and normally
that's what of the valkan nations had to
do because if you don't they would kill
and it would be a massacre of everyone
and it was a very horrific thing and
there's sources uh you know taking the
boys and mothers and are are crying and
fathers who do dare stand up get killed
anyway when they came to Vlad and they
said okay it's time we need we need x
amount of I forgot the money it's
written in the book and x amount of boys
and uh he said nope and basically and
not only that to add insult to interest
is they're wearing their turbons. He
said, and he knew perfectly well because
he grew up amongst the Ottomans. But he
asked him, why don't you remove your
turbons when you're in my presence and
they said it's our religion as you know,
etc., etc. So, he had he had their
turbons nailed to their heads. So,
that's the kind of guy Vlad was. And
it's good to keep in mind. I mean, yeah,
he definitely had a dark sense of humor,
if you want to put it that way. And he
sent them back to Muhammad basically
saying, "That's my answer about giving
you our youth." And then war was
declared on him over and over. And the
thing is, and this is where the vampire
legend comes from, is you know, he
witnessed impaling, which was actually
perfected by the Ottomans in his youth.
And uh when you're an outnumbered um
victim, okay, and I talk about the
numbers, but there was like maybe one
Wakian for every 20 Ottomans. And the
Wakian was fighting with a, you know,
pitchforks. I mean, and and no armor, no
nothing. So he had to blah engage in
basically terror tactics, guerrilla
warfare against this massive behemoth
army that entered into uh Wakia. And in
fact, Muhammad II came with it. That's
how much how interested he was in
getting Vlad's head. Anyway, he actually
beat him uh Vlad in that particular
campaign. I think it was in 14 I want.
It's in the book 50 maybe six I believe
or something around then. or I may be
confusing that with the uh the siege of
>> Yeah, your book was fascinating and uh
it made me do a deep dive uh and I got
all these other books. I just started
becoming obsessed with learning about
the historic or Vlad Dracula. Um history
is always so much more interesting than
movies, you know, and I know they've
tried to do all these movies about it.
Seems to me that he tried to fight
terror or terrorism with terror and beat
them at their own game. Yeah,
>> your next book is going to be the two
swords of Christ. Um, which is going to
be fascinating. And um, I there'll be a
lot of Christians though that I would
think are really uneasy about that that
that think that following Jesus means
turning the other cheek and just a total
pacifism. How do you respond to that?
>> Yeah, that's a good question. So, that
that goes back again to one's knowledge
of history. Um, in my youth before I did
all my delving into these historical
studies, I would have agreed, right?
because that's how it's taught and it
seems very much like look Jesus is you
know he's always preaching forgiveness
etc. So obviously we all have to behave
that way. And then you read history and
find out well no actually the
overwhelming majority of preodern
Christians did not think and believe
that way and they had the same
scriptures and they talked about it and
they grappled with various uh um script
you know verses try to how how to
understand it. In fact, uh the two
swords, that's a verse that comes from
Christ, uh where where he orders, he
tells his disciples, "Sell their cloaks
and go buy a sword." And they say,
"Look, Lord, here are two swords." And
he says, "That is enough." Now, here's a
perfect example. Modern day Christians,
what does that mean? Means absolutely
nothing. It's just uh it's nothing. It's
I don't even know how they symbolize it.
Uh I I've heard them say that when he
says, "This is enough that he's saying,
"Oh, you idiots, that's enough." What do
you mean two swords? I'm not talking
about real swords in which case so he's
what what was the whole thing about
selling your garment buying a sword
anyway no one thought of it that way in
the premodern era what it meant was that
uh that Christians will always encounter
two kinds of foes a material a corporeal
foe human foe and a spiritual or
incorporeal uh foe the demons you know
the principalities that you we were
talking about earlier and so you needed
two swords and that's why Christ said
that is enough because that's all you
need. One for that, one for that. Um,
and so that was so that's a perfect
example of coming across things. And
again, if you read it just with a modern
lens and listen to the sort of exugesus
of modern day Christians, it really
means absolutely nothing that verse, but
obviously he said it for a reason. At
least the preodern and definitely the
medieval interpretation makes sense. It
makes a lot of sense actually. And
that's so that's how they uh early you
know when you hear about crusaders or
even were so the crusaders as we know of
course are Christians who took the sword
took the cross and went to fight and die
uh on behalf of Christendom in the holy
land. We can talk about the particulars,
but what I wrote about is the creme de
la creme, the knights of the military
orders, specifically the two main ones,
which would be the temple and the
hospital. And uh what's interesting
about these guys is because in today's
climate, religious climate, the more of
a Christian you become, the more
essentially of a doormat you become. You
become a harmless, you know, nothing.
These guys were a lot more pious than
what you would call a secular crusader
and they were a lot more militant. Okay,
so it's very interesting how did they uh
they had no problems merging the twain
together in their life or in their mind.
And in the book I get into of course the
theology and the doctrines and the
justification for their way of thinking
and uh but you can but these guys really
represent hardcore militancy hardcore
commitment to martyrdom which many of
them did and it's very gory um in that
book because they would just not let up
the fight to them you know Christendom
Christ fellow Christians were things to
fight for in this world because this
world is violent there are enemies
and it just won't do. And we know this
logically, you and I, no matter how
passive of a Christian you want to be. I
I'm I'm waiting for the Christian who
will come up and tell me, okay, here's
my question. If I say to you as a
Christian and you're married and you
have a wife and let's say daughters and
sons and someone breaks in and the only
and he's going to kill and he's going to
rape and destroy their lives and the
only way you can stop him is to kill,
are you really going to tell me no? I
mean, because I don't I I can't believe
Jesus would say that. I can't believe if
Jesus was there and I asked him that
question that he would say no. Um, and
in fact, we know this and to go back to
the theology that supports the two
swords idea, we know this because just
war theory is very much based on a lot
of Jesus's implicit responses. So for
example um when the centurion comes to
him and asks for his servant to be
healed and and Christ heals him. Uh what
does Jesus do every time that he commits
performs a miracle? He tells people to
repent, right? He didn't do that to the
centurion. He and who is the centurion?
This he know Jesus knows this is a man
who is in charge of non-stop bloodshed.
Okay? A Roman centurion. You can
imagine. Okay? Did Jesus once say, "Hey,
quit the Roman army." No, he didn't. So
that it was seen by the proponents of
just war theory going all the way back
to Augustine as justification that yes
you can defend with violence uh
aggression and no one had a problem.
Same thing with John the Baptist uh you
know these soldiers come to him and say
what must we do to be saved. He didn't
say leave the army. He said be content
with your wages. So if anything he
actually validated what they were doing
which is warfare. Okay. So I think uh
you know this is this is good because we
are very much uh kind of holistically
responding to everything. I'm showing
you again how history dispels a lot of
the things that we just take for granted
even as Christians. Um and you know you
look around you how Christianity is
taught. No one wants to ever violence is
about the worst thing to preodern
Christians morality was much worse or by
which I mean immorality. Okay. It was
much worse for immorality to go on
unchecked than to perform violence.
violence was actually okay so what it's
physical pain and in fact this really
underscores why even modern day
Christians have have a very
materialistic mentality because if you
think violence and physical harm is the
absolute worst thing and it seems like a
lot of Christians do then you're missing
the idea that the metaphysical damage
that happens through immorality for
example is much worse and in fact is
what drove so much of uh Christian um
resistance and Christian warfare it was
the immorality but today it seems like a
lot Christians have missed sight of that
as long as you're not physically harming
anyone. Well, I mean, look around you in
the west, the the depraved immorality
that not not only is allowed to permeate
and spread and metastasize unchecked,
but we have to celebrate it too. Okay,
so that that really gives you an idea
and hence once again why it's very
important to become acquainted with
history and that's also why I wrote that
specific book, The Two Swords of Christ.
That book is really my contribution to
show that that sort of thing, violence
and warfare was very much understood
through a Christian paradigm. And in
fact, the ones who were the most
religious, these guys were essentially
monks were the most militant. And so the
two could actually live together in
harmony.
Yeah, it's interesting that you
mentioned Augustine because um you know
now I he's the father of the just war
theory and uh and now where he was in
North Africa is predominantly Muslim
>> and you see it even today with Nigeria
and the slaughter of Christians by Boo
Haram and and other Islamic groups. Um
it it really is a case of there is a
time like you say if somebody in in
invades your home or um tries to you
know destroy your family of course the
loving thing to do the Christian thing
to do is to protect them is to no
greater love Jesus says as a man than
this that he lay down his life for his
friends. Surely we would do that to
protect ourselves. Um it's
>> and before we continue, just to add on
another final important point. Um
remember Jesus engaged in violence,
>> right,
>> in the temple.
>> He made a cord. He kicked he whipped
people
>> and he got violent and he hurled tables.
We know that. Okay. So in and of itself,
it's hard to say violence is really a
neutral means or a tool. It's not
immoral. It's not evil in and of itself
because it depends on what the violence
is for. If you're defending against
unchecked aggression, then it's not
evil. Okay? And what Christ did in that
context, you know, he was defending the
honor of the temple, the honor of God.
Okay? That was a thing. And he got angry
and he engaged in violence. So the thing
is, for some reason, modern day uh
Christianity has stripped away all of
that. And it's now, like I said, it's
you become a doormat, which only helps
evil, unchecked evil. I mean, think
about it. the the greatest enemies of
Christianity love this kind of
Christianity because it does nothing. It
all it does is it just acquiesces to
anything and turns the other cheek.
That's not real historic Christianity
and it's not the kind of Christianity
that Christ actually um preached.
I might just pivot for a moment and talk
about your YouTube channel when you've
produced a lot of excellent resources on
there. Um some of them have just been
quite literally jaw-dropping. uh if if I
can discuss a few of them with you
because I I think they've been
excellent, really provocative and and
thoughtful. The first one I wanted to
talk to you about was uh you were
talking about um one of the examples
from the hadiths about who wrote
Muhammad.
>> Um and I I just couldn't believe um and
I had to like Google and think is this
true? Is this what is going on? Can you
explain very quickly for our listeners
um as an example of of what happened in
Muhammad's life? Sure. And uh but first
first um I have to give you the sort of
the the background story. The reason I
did that video, the the point is there's
a lot of unflattering things about
Muhammad in the Islamic sources. And so
there's been this recent debate about
people saying Muhammad never existed.
And one of the arguments that I and
others make is, well, if he never
existed and if he was made up, well, you
would make a purely clean igioraphical
prophet who is absolutely unassalable.
And yet Islamic sources are full of
embarrassing things which sort of
indicate that this is a real recording
of something. Um so in that particular
one I used it. That's why I made that
video. I was trying to show you an
example and it's basically based on a
hadith or hadiths um about which is um
you know recorded sayings and this one
comes from
which is actually a very authoritative
one and a very old one. And uh the long
and short of it is Muhammad goes out
into uh the desert at night and he takes
his friend and his friend is the
narrator. So that's how we know the
story and he makes a line in the sand
and says stand behind there and do not
cross it no matter what you see because
if you do you'll die. And his friend's
like okay Muhammad takes off uh for he
his friend says you know the the
distance of a throne stone whatever that
exactly means. Then his friend says,
"Then I saw what appeared to be Alzot."
Now Alzot are known as a dark-skinned
according to the Arabic um ethnographies
written around that time. They're sort
of a Pakistani or Indian people who were
laborers in Arabia at that time. And we
also have descriptions of them because
the Arabs liked to be very graphic about
them. And they and they among one of the
descriptions which I mentioned and I
document in the video is that they are
very libitous with a large fallacus.
Okay. All right. And anyway, so he says
he saw what appeared to be Alz and
they're naked and they all started to
ride Muhammad. Now ride Muhammad in
Arabic is just like in English. It could
mean like ride him like a horse or a
bicycle or it could have a more carnal
connotation. Okay? And that's all it
says. And then it says and and and one
of them came towards me, the narrator,
but apparently couldn't get past the
line. and he sat down because he was
terrified. Sitting down implies that
he's trying to you know apparently uh
you know conceal the one area they're
being they're attacking. I don't know I
mean what the implication is but then
and then the sun rises and they all
start leaving and Muhammad approaches
him looking like limping and in pain and
um lays down gently and puts his head in
his friend's lap and passes out. Okay,
so obviously not the most flattering um
thing and this is one of those things
that always gets hidden and it creates a
lot of anger and fighting in the Arab
world when they hear about this and they
tell you know they claim that this is
the jin and this is the night of the jin
when Muhammad went and preached the
Quran to the jin and they're crowding
around him which you know be that as it
may the fact is it when he says alut
that is a real ethno people he didn't
say jin right so um it's whatever that I
only brought that up ultimately because
I was trying to make a greater point.
Um, it's not my intention to mock or
insult Muslims, but the fact is there's
a lot of these out there, a lot of these
sort of hadiths which Muslims do not
want non-Muslims to know about.
>> Yeah. Look, it's it's fascinating
particularly when um you know this is a
legitimate part of the hadits you know
and uh and as you say you know it's part
of the the sacred tradition within Islam
and uh I was fascinated because you know
so many people would if you straight
away talked about Islam particularly
secular people they the one criticism
they'd have is oh yes they throw
homosexuals off the top of Ruths how how
do they respond when they know that well
there was at least some homosexual
interaction or proclivities even with
Muhammad. What what do they do with
that?
>> I mean they will Okay, so this hadith
they've decided now it's it's a weak
hadith. Okay, which there's no reason
for that because it was by it's in in
Ahmed bin humble and I even gave more in
the in the video I made. I gave more
compelling reasons why it wasn't
considered a weak hadith. Um or you know
or they'll say okay they'll argue the
word ride. They'll say, "Oh, that's
metaphor." Kind of like uh sometimes
when um you know, if I say it's a
crowded bus, the people are riding one
another, it means like it was so
crowded. So the jin were crowding. Yeah.
So I mean, if if you're determined not
to believe the implications of it, you
can do that. Okay. Because but but
attacks on homosexuals that is actually
more firm in Islamic Sharia. So that's
why it'll be there. But the thing with
Islamic law and Islamic Sharia is it's
been likened to a large supermarket
where you can just take and pick what
you like and choose. And um it's
actually more flexible than people
think. It's it's not as draconian. It is
draconian but uh it actually allows
Muslims a much flexibility especially
vis non-Muslims because in the end it's
all about um empowering Islam. And so
this is where for example a lot of
license is given to Muslims to deceive
non-Muslims even though strictly
speaking a Muslim shouldn't lie. But
when it comes to the infidel and if your
lie is going to help Muslims or Islam
then you can lie. Okay. So in that it's
in that vein. So the religion is you
know it's it's just a lot of you can do
a lot of things with it if you want. Um
there especially with the hadith because
there's there's countless hadith. There
are volumes. So if you want to find
something that justifies anything you
will find it.
>> Wow. I mean, another excellent video you
just put out talking about Azot was
England and how there's been a massive
influx of Muslim people from Pakistan,
India, uh, you know, all around the
world. Um, and you talk about the St.
George flag. A friend of mine was
actually in the UK recently and there
was, you know, the Tommy Robinson
rallies and things like that against and
Tommy Robinson famous for the Pakistani
grooming gangs and um you know where he
grew up in England, it's now dominated
by Muslims. Um what do you think is the
significance or do you think there is a
significance of the St. George's Cross?
>> Oh yeah. Um and and that's the irony of
it. those people who who are defending
it. Um I mean some do know but a lot of
them don't really know just how
applicable it is to the current
situation because in the current
situation you got English people
rallying to the flag as a as a show of
defiance against this influx of migrants
many of them alut from Pakistan and
elsewhere Muslims and and Africa and and
all that sort of thing. So on the one
hand it could be seen as you know we're
just patriots going back to our flag
making a defiant stance against this
sort of uh migrant influx. On the other
hand it's actually perfectly applicable.
Um you know you mentioned the grooming
gangs and of course Muslims praying on
um you know native British girls is a
thing you know definitely it's actually
all throughout Western Europe but
especially in Britain and in the UK. So
the but the St. George flag. The irony
of it is it actually so it goes back to
the Templars, the Knights of the
Templars in my in my new book. And what
it meant was red is red the red cross is
martyrdom. Okay? And the white is I'm a
I'm a knight who's going to live a pure
life. And that's what they were. Okay?
But it gained um a lot of traction with
other crusaders after the Templars
adopted it, including um the Brits or
the English when they came uh on their
crusades and including Richard Linhardt,
Richard the first. uh he was and it also
got fused with St. George who was a
military saint um because he was a
soldier during the Roman Empire I
believe in the second or third century
he was martyed um because he wouldn't
renounce Christ but he was also a
warrior so he became the patron saint
for crusaders especially and his and
again he got he sort of got amalgamated
with the red cross and the white so that
all became one and the English very much
uh gravitated towards it and after uh
King Richard you have um you know his
grand nephew I guess Edward first
another crusader who really championed
that that flag and St. George and
brought it back and sort of patronized
it and then eventually became the
identity the flag of England. Um, so
what's interesting is, you know, the
those who are rallying to it today,
these English people, and they're
fighting against Muslims. That is what
it was always about. That flag of
England was actually founded on
Europeans, including English, fighting
Muslims who were doing the same sorts of
things that they're doing now in
England. And it's a perfect example of
those who forget history. Repeat it
because you forgot the meaning of your
flag and you brought in countless
Muslims. Lo and behold, look what
they're doing. So now you have to fight
them in your own territory as opposed to
when you had to go to the Holy Land and
fight them there in an effort to
liberate the land and help Christians
over there.
>> Yeah, that I mean that's it's a
fascinating connection and and I guess a
really good example of like what George
Orwell talks about about he who controls
history, you know, controls the present
then controls the future. Um, another
fascinating debate that you've had, and
some people listening to this will be
like, "What on earth is that about, but
you debated Dr. J. Smith about whether
or not Muhammad even existed?" And, uh,
I've got to say, when I first saw this
online, I was like, "What?" Um, but I
thought you had a very good rebuttal.
Um, can you give us a quick summary
again? Um what was Jay saying and why
you think I think you listed about maybe
eight or 10 points on on why one of them
being you know obviously the hadiths but
can you explain um why you think he a
existed and b it's important?
>> Well the reason I think he existed is
because he existed and um okay it goes
back you have to understand Jay Smith is
a good guy. I like him personally, but
you know, he's really a pmicist and his
whole his whole purpose is to try to
overthrow Islam, which may be seen as a
noble endeavor through this idea of
trying to get people to believe Muhammad
never existed. The only problem is this
idea seems to always be directed at
Christians and non-Muslims where it
actually creates mischief. It doesn't
even help because if I'm a non-Muslim,
and I am, and I believe Muhammad
existed, and let's say you believe he
didn't exist, well, we believe the same
thing actually. Okay. I believe that
Muslims are following a false prophet.
Jay believes Muslims are are following a
false a madeup prophet. It really
doesn't change a whole lot. In the end,
we both are that's why we're both
disbelievers. But I do think it has a
lot of um a lot of uh it creates a lot
of problems for Westerners when they
actually start thinking that Muhammad
didn't exist because then they don't
take it too seriously. They think, "Oh,
this is destined to blow over. Muslims
are going to wake up. All the evidence
is there." there and as I've explained
in videos and in my day debates it's
nothing like that but you know the long
and short of it is the person that Jay
Smith actually um invokes often and who
did who was the pioneer of the of the
skepticism towards um Islamic histo
early Islamic history and
historioggraphy is Patricia Crona who
wrote this book Hagarism and she in my
debate with him I quoted her flat out
says of course Muhammad existed and we
have more historical evidence for him
than Jesus and Buddha. Okay. So, I mean,
this is the skeptical camp talking. So,
that's why, of course, uh I I think it's
ridiculous to say it's it he didn't
exist. It's a PMIC. Um and you know,
people want to use it against Muslims.
Fine. But for some reason, they're not.
And probably because no Muslim even
wants to hear it. They laugh at it. It I
mean, I I gave the analogy of how weak
this is by by showing you how the same
this always happens. Nobody does this to
historical figures that are irrelevant.
Now, no one's going to come and tell you
Alexander the Great never existed. even
though the historical evidence for him
is much slighter than Muhammad. So why
do they say Muhammad? Why did they say
Jesus didn't exist? Because these people
have importance today and their enemies
are trying to debunk them. So you know
Jesus according to all these scholars
decades ago especially they never
existed. Same arguments. So again it's a
very pmical argument. It's rooted in
religion. It's not about history. And um
I think it's again if one wants to
entertain it, if one wants to use it as
a pyic against Muslims, more power to
you. But that's not what happens. What
happens is it creates confusion among
among non-Muslims about the origins of
Islam and you know and its significance.
So that's why I think you know you're
better off kind of shelving it.
>> I mean I I could talk to you about these
separate topics and all day. I mean
they're fascinating. I'd really commend
people listening to this, watching this,
go check out Dr. Abraham's uh YouTube
channel. It's excellent. Lots of really
terrific resources and you can dig
deeper into them. Um uh what the other
thing that really struck me about you,
I'm actually quite jealous. Um is uh cuz
uh one of my other heroes is Victor
Davis Hansen who you studied under when
you were um doing your thesis on the
battle of Yuk uh I think is how you
pronounce it. Um now he's a I think a
first rate scholar. um and a very
courageous um cultural political
commentator today. Can you explain
something of the influence and and I
guess benefit of having studied under
him?
>> Yeah. Yeah. He was my professor back in
the late 90s at California State
University in Fresno. Um so it's almost
been 30 years actually since we've known
each other. But he also we he became a
friend and a mentor. He'd often have uh
gettogethers at his farmhouse and you
know a few college students were invited
by I among them and it was always great
and you know very very he's very um good
to talk with. He's very much like what
you see actually. So when you see him on
video that's the real him that when you
talk to him oneonone it's sort of very
similar. Um and yeah of course the
benefits uh he really helped me with my
first book um that's how it happened. my
first book, The Al-Qaeda Reader, which
came out in 2007. Okay, so we're going
almost on 20 years now. I was working at
the Library of Congress, and I came
across writings in Arabic by al-Qaeda.
And anyway, I was like, "Wow, this would
be good for me to translate." And I
contacted him and uh he was like, he
said, "Yeah, I would." And he connected
me with his literary representatives.
And long story short, I got a major book
deal out of it with Double Day Books.
And that became my first uh book. And
you know, after that, it was history. I
just that's what I continue doing uh
writing and being a fellow at various
think tanks. Um but we're still uh you
know I think uh we emailed yesterday so
we're still in touch. Um and uh
hopefully actually I'm trying to I'm
trying to talk him into doing an
interview with me on my channel maybe
about my two books. Um I think that'd be
great. Ah that'd be brilliant. Now I got
to ask one final question uh which is
probably if people are watching this uh
if you if you're just listening to this
on Spotify you're not going to
understand this but if you're watching
this or you've seen Dr. Abraham before I
got to say, you know, brother, you got
the guns and obviously, you know, you
you work out, you uh we talked earlier
about muscular Christianity. Um, have
you been into bodybuilding um in the
past? And and if so, how does that
interplay with, you know, your academic
and intellectual pursuits?
>> Yeah, I um well, it starts off when I
was very very young, like 13, 14. I
started lifting weights. I just enjoyed
lifting weights and being strong and
muscular
and uh never mind the noob dog. Anyway,
um so uh and um I actually played
football in high school. So that I I
connected it with football and I was a I
played as a defensive end and I was
really good. I had a stack of letters
from colleges and that's what I was
going to be a football player. I was
going to go to some college and um play
football there. But then I tore my ACL
in my senior year. It was really really
bad. Um I'm still suffering from that
injury till now. But anyway, um I still
wanted to continue weightlifting and I
did. But I still but I wanted a reason,
a logic. So before it was football. Um
now it was just like I'm lifting weights
for nothing. And anyway, that's the how
the bodybuilding thing came. I couldn't
be a powerlifter. I didn't have that
kind of strength and I ended up tearing
muscles trying to overload my my
muscles. But making them big was easy.
That kind of came by. So I body I
dabbled with bodybuilding in my teenage
years. I won the Mr. LA um I think in 93
and then I did other shows. I competed
with a guy who ended up being Mr.
Olympia, Jay Cutler actually,
>> but I was done with all that by the age
of 22. And uh I was just like I I never
really liked the bodybuilding lifestyle.
Um and that's I only did it again
because I needed a competitive outlet to
justify weightlifting as hard as I was.
I didn't I couldn't play football and I
didn't know what else to do. But anyway,
I stopped it and uh um because it just
wasn't for me. And I continued with a
weightlifting up until now. And uh as to
how one reconciles it with sort of
academic pursuits, I guess my whole
thing has always been to be balanced,
you know, and I don't I don't want to be
an armchair historian like Edward Gibbon
with a little pouch for a belly, you
know. I want to be both. And you know,
in a way that's what Victor Hansen is.
He's not he doesn't weightlift, but you
know, the guy's out there farming, uh
working the land with his hands still.
So I want to I don't want to be a
sedentary person. So, I I stayed with
the weightlifting and other forms of
athletics. And I think it's great. It
really helps give one a sort of balanced
um take on life and approach to life. Um
and I've, you know, and for the record,
I'm not advocating anyone has to lift
weights, but I do believe you should be
active. Do whatever. I also like bike
riding, for example. I think that's
great. Any kind of sport, any kind of
athletic, it's not about building
muscle. Um it's just uh you know,
whatever.
Oh, I think it's just great to
incorporate some sort of physical
sport in your life.
>> Yeah, I think it's it's interesting.
I've heard Victor Davis Hansen being
interviewed uh by uh by lots of people
uh in particular John Anderson here in
Australia, the former deputy prime
minister of Australia. He's got a
brilliant YouTube channel himself. Um
but he Victor Davis Hansen talks about
the ideal citizen is the philosopher
farmer. And there's something about
mixing like the activity being literally
grounded in farming but also being in
the books and I think you model that
interestingly as well as big as your
arms are I think the muscle in your
head. I'm really impressed and just in
awe of your I don't know how you do it
the the research and the scholarship
that goes in behind the books. Can I ask
you personally how do you keep up that
regime of of study? because I as I was
reading your book Sword and Scimitar U
for instance, I just thought I was
looking through the the footnotes and
the endotes and I'm like, "Wow." Um, how
do you maintain that that intellectual
rigor?
>> You know, it's funny. I did a live
stream recently sort of addressing that.
I talked about the books I read and and
my reading practices and habits. And the
long and short of it is basically a long
time ago I determined you know the most
important topics for me were history and
um also theology and philosophy which
kind of um you know inter interact with
each other in a way and so since my
youth since in my 20s I've had a regimen
where I'm always reading I used to be
I'd read history and theology and
philosophy all at once a little bit
every night but now I just will read one
book about history and then I'll go into
theology. Honestly though, nowadays
almost everything is history because
like I said, even when I'm interested in
theology, I'm interested in its
development in history. Um, I think
that's much more interesting and more
telling than abstract studies, which are
interesting in of themselves, but
they're academic in a way. Um, so yeah,
that that's my fun. It doesn't it
doesn't hurt that almost every time I
turn the TV on, there is absolutely
nothing to watch. Okay. So, that also
helps me go read uh because it's just
it's so boring. Everything is silly and
stupid and and top of the list is the
news. Okay. Because like I said, that's
just one big embarrassing distraction.
So, that gives me the the time and
wherewithal to continue the study.
>> Yeah, it'd be interesting um uh someday
to hear your thoughts. Um you say your
brother's a flaming Calvinist. Um it
sounds interesting. Um, but uh,
>> double predestination.
>> I'm sorry, what's that?
>> Double predestination, too.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Well, look, I'd be with him.
I I think I I've come to sort of similar
convictions, but um I'm interested
because um there's a I don't know if
you've ever heard of a um a very famous
theologian/prime minister of Holland
called Abraham Kyper. Um
>> sounds familiar.
>> Yeah, it is. He's worth looking into
because he actually did um a whole
volume on Islam and the impact of Islam
about a hundred years ago. Um and he's
very much developed um a very robust
theology of church and state. Um but
I've just got to ask you one final
question and this is sort of off you
know uh off script a little bit to the
side. It just reminded me because of
your dog in the background. Muhammad
himself didn't like dogs. What's that
about?
Yeah, I've done a video about that
actually. Oh, well um and sad to say
that one also has homosexual overtones
if you watch the video because yeah
again so the hadith is Muhammad ordered
you know uh at one point he ordered the
slaughter of all the dogs and people
went and started killing them. Then he
finally he said okay you you know as
long you can keep a dog if it helps you
and you keep it outside you can never
keep it out inside. If you keep it
inside, angels will never enter your
house. And um you but the black dog has
to be killed. All kinds of weird things.
But the reason that he said if you can't
if you keep a dog in your house, angels
won't enter and bless it. Hence the
homosexual reference is there's all
these other hadith that one of his best
friends, which people say he had an
affair with because he's always
described as being the most beautiful
man in Arabia, okay? that this guy that
sometimes Gabriel would vis Gabriel the
angel supposedly visited Muhammad and
revealed the Quran to him that sometimes
Gabriel would visit him in the guise of
this man. Okay? And that is because if
you look into the hadith um this guy
would come at night and whenever someone
of Muhammad's wives were at the house
and they saw him Muhammad would be well
that's just Gabriel that's why he's
visiting me at 3:00 a.m. in the evening.
Okay. I mean, this is all in their
sources, but there's one one story where
he came and he wouldn't enter the house
and Muhammad waited and waited for his
friend and then he saw a little dog
under like I don't know under the bed
and he yelled at Aisha and he said, "Why
is this dog here? Where'd he come from?"
She says, "I don't know. We just crept
in and he ordered it out and then um his
friend came in." So that's the idea of
why if you have a a dog in your house,
angels won't visit you. It's based on
this rather sorted tale. Um, yeah.
>> So, you could say Muhammad really put
the gay back into Gabriel. Um,
>> but I mean I mean you also mentioned
Aisha who was a child bride which is I
would have thought the other really
embarrassing thing for Muslims because
he married her quite young and then
consummated her the marriage quite young
as well. Uh, look, there's so many
things that I would love to talk to you
about. Um, but we've run out of time. I
really do appreciate you giving us your
time. Um, thank you for what you're
producing. Really looking forward to
your to your new book. Um, every
blessing to you and, uh, we hope that we
can talk to you again in the future.
>> Thanks very much, Mark. I appreciate it.
Yeah, I look forward to it.
>> All right. This has been Mark Power for
AP's Profiles in Christian Living. I
hope you've enjoyed this episode and I
look forward to seeing you next time.
[Music]